I work for the president I'm Gerard
Butler and I am which never actors
playing the president this time Trump
he's gonna protect Trump this movie
angel has fallen the Lionsgate new movie
just in time for John wick promote their
next action flick Gerard Butler's Ameri
naked over how he can't do it for ya
cause I am a law-abiding citizen it's
like his mouth
I've been watching those linguist breaks
down accents videos and I feel like his
mouth never leaves the Scottish preset
even when he's doing the American no he
doesn't hmm hey you angels fallen let's
check out the third installment to the
Holland's that other guy I know is
French
[Music]
man do you monetize the president it's
cold out here
sorry hey anything to get out of DC for
a while Mike I'm selecting you for
Secret Service Director congratulations
or given my best shot Raymond is
president notion
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
did you find me Curie for the present
how do you think that
I was gonna say Magog
[Music]
[Laughter]
my daughter she was taken yeah
awesome I feel like this movie's gonna
have a lot of shots of Morgan Freeman
looking wide-eyed a jarred Butler while
he explains tactics that look a lot
better than I thought it would
it's ever looked intense I mean the the
impression the first film left on me is
that the stuff I truly enjoyed were the
action moments with Gerard Butler so in
that way this kind of has that quality
but yeah it looks like they definitely
stepped up just the grittiness of the
action for sure well the guy they got to
direct this one I forget his name but he
he did that new niccola cost of that the
person move Aldo he did that prison
movie shot-caller oh and he also did
that dwayne johnson movie snitch I think
Fallon which are all these like very
gritty personal action dramas that are
always in like the 60% to your movies
you know they're pretty and I I can feel
that sensibility being brought to here
because it's a generic plot as usual
it's fall in this universe alone the
president's life has been attempted yes
this guy just really hates working for
the president I could see why they try
to kill the president after a while he's
probably just cracked like screw it I'm
gonna do it myself
yeah it's inevitable why not keep
getting in trouble anyway I hate
protecting the president I don't know
why I still have this job and at the
same time I bit Morgan Freeman's like
why a great choice at the beginning of
this trailer promoting Mike yeah just in
time to get saved from drones yes Aaron
Eckhart just retired or his term was up
but I I'm really liking to see what
would Mike the famous character Mike
Mike banning yes Mike banning their
famous character drew our Butler's plan
I'm I'm looking forward to it because I
feel like they're borrowing from a lot
of action movies that I personally
really like you know he gets some born
vibes even get some vibes of the
fugitive mm-hm
obviously not just because he's a
fugitive but it sort of feels like the
fugitive at times a little bit of
law-abiding citizen cuz you know he's in
that orange jumpsuit and he gets
arrested for a minute and he's a
law-abiding citizen who's being framed
you did it John you linked it thank you
for doing that and I I like I'm actually
I'm pretty impressed by this because it
feels very personal I feel like we're
gonna get something I don't know if it's
character driven but I feel like we're
gonna get a lot more emotional intensity
as opposed to just draw our Butler
playing intense he's put in a position
where his life is on the line he's being
framed it's it's sort of borrowing a
little bit from like the mission
impossible franchise to how Ethan Hunt
has always tried just doing the right
thing and he keeps getting set up and he
keeps having to go rogue yeah and and I
feel kind of that element here I mean
yeah you got all the cliches stuff you
know this whole plot didn't even even
with the day if it's not your dad who's
dude living in the woods or mentor yeah
the old buddy from the war John beard
has explosions and in the woods
initially reluctant but then it's clear
that he's really good yeah this is
probably gonna die I wouldn't be
surprised if he died to add more
personal weight it's probably all his
lost moment of this movie before we get
into the crazy finale that's kind of the
impression I'm getting I just hope Nick
Nolte himself doesn't die every time he
shows up now I'm always like oh he's so
terrible I'm worried but I think he's
gonna die I think you mean dying real
life yes you think he's gonna die in
real life
he's either never gonna die or he's
gonna die in like 20 minutes cuz like
every time I see him now I'm like a
[ __ ] Nick Nolte this is the first time
he seems like like an old dude you know
the first time no well when I saw him
he's been liking what I see for 20 years
yeah yeah but but the thing is he's been
an old dude for 20 years when I saw him
in the ridiculous six I was like oh but
you don't look like he was like a tough
old dude and now he just seems like he's
actually getting old like I hear his
voice I'm like all you sound like you're
gonna fall over man like perhaps worried
about Nick Nolte well I mean I feel like
he's gonna be just fine I'm gonna be I'm
sure he will be I'm sure he's gonna be
great and then being father and son yeah
I can see that happen American father
Scottish boy yeah I taught you
everything you know including this
accent Jada pinkett-smith is playing the
Tommy Lee Jones character yeah totally
it's always cool to see her while her
husband is doing great renditions of
Prince Ollie
and we got Danny Huston playing who I
can only assume is the villain that
they're not really teasing at it all in
this tree yeah I'm I'm I also really
like they're doing it again old man Mike
you know he looks a lot older I mean
it's been a few years since London uh
spawn I'm pretty surprised we're getting
a sequel because Olympus has fallen was
a big hit London has fallen was I don't
want to call that being a hit I
remembered that actually really
underperforming come especially compared
to Olympus has fallen yeah and a little
taken aback to be though I was really
committed to this yeah I'm surprised
that this is three films deep especially
because yeah lympus has fallen dropped
around the time White House down came
out if anything I thought that would be
the one that got the franchise because
that was even more like well received at
least on the strength of Channing Tatum
but hey man I'm always happy to see
Gerard Butler getting work well that
movie though was wasn't a box-office
success where Olympus has fallen was a
box-office success okay
because Olympus has fallen has come out
I came out first that's what you got to
do you got to just be the first one to
come out doesn't even matter which one's
better as long as you're the first one
to come out I like that tie they had to
work in the word angel already guardian
angel well yeah because now they're like
oh we're not in a place that's fallen
anymore what do we do and I appreciate
that direction this I think this could
have easily turned into a taken 3
situation and it seems like they're
actually stepping up their game to make
something a lot more personally intense
so I got it you know I got
I thought we were gonna be just be in
for another dumb-looking movie yeah I
thought like three true movies this deep
yeah how many freakin places is gonna
have to protect with the presidents that
I'm I'm kind of kind of surprised by how
much I like its trailer it's a solid set
up it looks intense the action
especially it looks cool fingers crime
always got my fingers crossed for Jerry
B I want him to enjoy success and I
don't think whatever Morgan Freeman had
done that you know when people were
calling him out in real life
I was wondering oh that if I don't think
that's as bad as some other people you
know so is it like a thing where he's
like okay this is bad behavior you
shouldn't do it but it's not like you're
making crime happen right now I guess it
I don't know I'm not an expert on the
Morgan Freeman I don't know here's a
little creepy married is I don't care he
married his daughter I don't care at
this point for this movie I'm gonna
watch for Gerard Butler to kick a bunch
of asses and Morgan Freeman I'll have no
he'll be in there for 10 minutes who
cares whatever he's a little really cool
after yeah we just accepted him back I
no worries I don't know so many people
are gonna learn about now until really
if it was if it was way worse than it
was I thought he would have heard about
it yes it are in the fame that he has if
he has something truly horrific he would
have been canceled exactly yeah I think
you just made some people very
uncomfortable which is bad too because
Freeman hasn't fallen hey that's the net
job and is the drug mother has to save
Morgan Freeman's reputation nuts
that's hilarious that's good all my own
citizens yeah thanks and subscribe click
that notification PO see I see